- SNL honestly hasn't
changed that much.
What's really changed is you.
Life fucked you so
hard to the point
that recurring characters
and famous actors struggling
to read cue cards isn't
what it used to be.
SNL isn't for you anymore.
You don't even know who most
of the musical guests are.
The Weeknd is just
one guy, not a band.
My bones are frail.
It's hard to admit
that you're older,
the gray pubes are coming in,
and that Beck Bennett is this
generation's Phil Hartman.
Oh yes.
Let that sink in for a
minute, why don't ya?
Ninjas suck.
If you have to fight
a bunch of ninjas,
they all get knocked out easily.
If you have to fight one by
itself, it takes forever.
They're either an empty promise
or a lingering fart
on the elevator
that needs to just
slowly fade away.
Folks rant and rave about how
brilliantly bad The Room is,
but honestly, it's
just really boring.
An excentric, rich,
foreign weirdo named Tommy,
who has the same type
of Eurotrash accent
as every man that lets a girl
poop on his chest in a porn
is amusing for about
the first 15 minutes.
And he sincerely tried his best.
He did as good a
job making a movie
as I would running
the obstacle courses
on American Ninja Warrior.
There are truly bad movies
like the 2015 Fantastic Four,
or Jupiter Accending
that cost hundreds
of millions to make
and have an army
of crew members,
and yet they make no sense
and contains zero fun.
Before we make fun
of Tommy Wiseau
and the way he says, "You're
tearing me apart, Lisa",
let's remember every
six months a bunch
of British white guys
pretend to be Egyptian
and scream a lot, and
that is so much worse.
I'm looking at you, Noah,
gods of Egypt, exegists,
everything else I've seen
on a plane when I'm alone.